let's talk about vaccinations a little
bit we're going to cover vaccinations in
more detail on an upcoming program as it
relates to the virus but today I want to
talk about two prominent from pused
sycophants who have announced that they
will not accept any Hirono virus vaccine
that is associated in any way with Bill
Gates now for me this entire narrative
about you know the bulette benevolent
billionaires versus the evil
billionaires it's a pretty silly one my
I apply a more structural understanding
to this issue of billionaires and the
sociology and the economics of
billionaires I believe most billionaires
as people are pretty good people but
there are systemic components in our
society that favor the very rich which
often lead to unproductive self-centered
behavior on the part of billionaires in
huge corporations so you know during the
Bernie campaign there was a lot of
discussion about why does this candidate
or that candidate hate billionaires and
every candidate addressed it differently
but my view has always been this is not
about billionaires as people it's about
the positioning of billionaires and
policy in a society that at a structural
level allows and encourages certain
behaviors where you see billionaires
created and that's really the crux of
what we're trying to deal with so my
point is talking about these are the
good billionaires and these are the bad
billionaires seems like a pretty fraught
experiment to me that being said when
you look at Bill Gates as an individual
versus you know Koch brothers as
individuals and you look at what Bill
Gates has funded versus the things that
Koch brothers have funded in addition I
get Koch brothers found fund medicine
and some good things as well you look at
Bill and Melinda Gates they have lobbied
other billionaires to give away as much
of their wealth as possible Bill Gates
has dedicated himself for a very long
time to funding and finding cures and
solutions to everything from sanitation
and developing nations vaccines for
pandemics etc yeah Bill Gates doesn't
want to pay a wealth tax he's a
billionaire
when Elizabeth Warren put out her wealth
tax proposal he's
said he scoffed at it he barked at it
right but if we had more billionaires
like Bill Gates than the Koch brothers
we would be better off all else being
equal so this gets us now to coronavirus
the Gates Foundation is funding
development research and possible
factories where seven different
coronavirus vaccines could be produced
now this is a huge waste of money in a
literal sense and what I mean by that is
in order to have capacity to produce
enough vaccines to really distribute
them to enough people to build herd
immunity you have to take a chance on an
unproven vaccine you have to start
building infrastructure to produce
unproven vaccines there are seven
promising vaccine candidates right now
for coronavirus Bill Gates is already
funding factories to produce seven
different vaccines in all likelihood six
of those seven will not end up being the
vaccine okay that's a really good thing
that he is doing and his mere
involvement in vaccination is causing
conspiracy theory explosions a girl I
went to high school with has been
posting a lot of this stuff on her
Facebook page she's a big trumpet I had
to unfollow her Donald Trump's friends
diamond and silk are spreading the same
disinformation take a look at this
including conspiracies about Bill Gates
and population control and other such
nonsense trying to vaccinate they felt
like stuff can start right there in
certain parts of that's what we don't
need to do not gonna make black people
not the guinea pig for this year I can't
be your experience or your project not
yes
today bill yes the surgeon the Surgeon
General was talking to as a matter of
fact he was treated today listen I tell
us what we need to know yeah but I
always look at the underbelly of what's
going on that's intuition in me yeah
that's my intuitive yeah Clark
counterpart yes uh-huh
what do you Bob to do here right because
what you not gonna do you
start vaccinating blackphone right and
we have to have a vaccination card just
to go to dinner you're not gonna do that
and and what it does it it'll start with
us first
right see they got us with slavery they
got us with Jim Crow not about the push
this here mass vaccination and listen
kudos if you make your vaccines for
people and you want to help em but I
have a problem receiving any vaccine
from any entity especially anybody like
Bill Gates who push for population
control the same thing that Margaret
Sanger pushed for abortions imagine
comparing Jim Crow to a corona virus
vaccine again as I've said before if
people were only endangering themselves
I would be much more resigned to a sort
of Darwinism uh uh in a sense as a sort
of Darwinistic perspective when it comes
to what these people are saying and
doing but diamond and silk have an
audience and they post stuff and people
see it and it starts to spread like a
virus itself bill gates population
control bad for black people don't
accept any vaccine that Bill Gates is
associated with as it is we are going to
have trouble actually getting the
vaccine to everybody both because of
supply issues and because of existing
anti-vaxxer sentiment and now this on
top of it so it's much like with the
virus if you don't social distance
you're putting other people at risk if
you convince people not to get the
vaccine the risk of spread grows
exponentially and our ability to achieve
herd immunity is diminished if you don't
get vaccinated you are putting other
people at risk and as we've seen with
the measles anti-vaxxers when you
convince more people not to get a
vaccine you actually create pockets of
outbreaks which is exactly what's been
happening with measles so this is
stunningly ignorant but dangerous
ignorant in the modern United States of
2020 is unfortunately common and it's
incredibly applauded in
SiC circles Donald Trump jr. and Donald
Trump himself will often retweet diamond
and silk they've been to the White House
meeting with Trump like this is really I
know I used the term weaponized too much
so I'm not going to use it but we are in
an acute idiocracy and the calls are
coming from inside the house so to speak
scary scary stuff
nor do VPN one of our sponsors is giving
you 70% off a three-year plan which is
just a little over three bucks a month
and you'll get an extra month free when
you go to Nord BPM comm slash David
Pakman or go to their website use the
coupon code David Pakman if you don't
use a VPN now is the time to start I
always use a VPN on my computer and my
phone it makes you totally anonymous
when you're browsing online you won't be
spied on websites can't track you around
the internet your data is safe from
hackers and Nord VPN is the one you want
to go with because they don't keep
records on your internet history they
double encrypt your data their servers
are super fast and they provide
unlimited bandwidth Nord VPN is giving
you 70% off a three-year plan that's
just over three bucks a month plus an
extra month free when you go to Nordby
pn comm slash david pakman i've put a
link right underneath the video or just
go to their website and use the coupon
code david pakman